だ社員として成功する人間と成功できない
人間を分ける決定要因は考え方あると、ま
、課長から部長に上がれない人間は器が
ちっちゃいんだかな。求めるものが
ちっちゃいんだと思うよ。自分はさ、どの
役職がふさわしいかって無意識のうちに
自分で決めてるのよ。青木サの人生額
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
は、昇の話でして、課長から部長に昇できない人の特徴と、ま、頭打ちになってしまう理由があれば教えてください。
ま、小心昇格を決めてるのは会社だからさ
、基本的にね、会社が定めた人事制度の中
で部長職に求められる能力要件っていうの
をまず自分自身がしっかりと意識してで
その実っていう言葉でね、表すんだけど
実績そのまず部長色としての数字的なもの
や役割というものを自分の主義主張では
なく実際の実績としてまず出してるかどう
か1つだよね。あとは会社に対する
ロイヤリティ、それからトップの真の補佐
としてあくまでも会社組織の理念の具限化
のためにそのある部署の責任者になって
いくのがやっぱり部長だから部のなので、
ま、ある意味では経営者でもあるんですよ
。も部の蝶としてで、そのことがトップ
から見て1日も早く役員にあげたい人間か
どうか、そういう存在なのかどうかだよね
。その逆に例えば会社のここが足りない、
あそこが足りない、もっと会社はこうある
べきだみたいなそういう発言をしてたら
もう器がちっちゃいと。うん。逆にそのか
を今持たせてるけどもちょっと人数減らし
た方がいいんじゃないかと。人を育てれて
ないよと。ていうのはもうそういう
マインドの人間って人を育てれないです
から。どこ見て仕事してるのっていうこと
が、ま、人事制度の中で上のランクに行け
ば行くほどムアの原点なんだけど、やっぱ
アイデア、思考から全てが生まれてくるの
で、その器、大きな前的な役員マインド
ぐらいの役員になる前に役員の思考を持っ
て仕事をしていったらどんどん役割が
大きくなるんじゃないですか。
れたことをしっかりこなしていったらおずと会社がその人を必要とするので上のポジションに上がってくるんではないかと思いますね。
ありがとうございます。
なんか頭打ちになってしまう人の特徴ってありますか?
うん。
能力的にその部長の能力じゃないってことだろうな。課長の能力なんだろうね。ま、
1つは
はい。僕なんかも今240人社員見てて、
こないだからあのXでもね、あのついたん
だけどうちの奥さんに聞いてみたのね。
なんでこれ240人社員てみんな成功しさ
せたいと思ってるし上がってくる人間、
上がれない人間色々いるけれども何が違う
と思うとそしたらうちの奥さんは一言です
よ。考え方の違いでしょって。考え方の
違いだと思う。だ社員として成功する人間
と成功できない人間を分ける決定要因は
考え方だとその問りだなとでもう1つ言っ
たのなんで俺うまくいってると思うって。
あ、そしたらパパいっつもうまくいくこと
ばっかり考えてるからね。てどうしたら
うまくいくかってことしか考えてない
じゃん。でもパパいつも言ってるじゃん。
人はその人が考えた通りになるって。その
問だと思うよって。なるほど。その問だな
と。いや、本当にそうなのだから。それを
今の話でね、言うと僕はやっぱり社長に
なるべくして社長になってるんですよ。
課長じゃないんだよ、僕の器は部長でも
ないんだよ。みんなにとって良いことを
考えてるから。もっと言ったら国のこと
まで考えてるからね。自分はさ、どの役職
がふさわしいかって無意識のうちに自分で
決めてるのよ。居心地がいいところが。
自分は課長ぐらいがちょうどいいとか。
自分は部長がちょうどいいとか、もう自分
はもう社長なるって決めてる人間は部長で
は満足しないでしょ。で、社長になれ
なかったとする。でも腰だんと狙ってると
思うよ。いつかは昔のあのトヨタのせいか
はクラウンだよ。いつかは社長だよ。
そんなもんだって。だから目指してる人が
多い社会の方がいいんだよ。だから求めよ
さらば与えられんでしょ。求めてないんだ
と思うよ。なんで教えましょう。苦痛を
感じるんですよ。負荷をこれ以上置いたく
ないとか。だからそれが器なんだよ。俺
もっと大きな負荷かけてもらいたいと思っ
てんだもん。逆境ある意味では大好物だ
から。それなぜなら成長に至る促進罪とし
て考えてない。もっと自分に負荷をかけて
いこう。そうやって今まで生きてきて、
こっからが本当の意味での勝負ですよ。
松下之さんは会長なった66歳ですからね
。そっからまた頑張ったんだから。で、
会長なってから会社が猛烈に伸びたんです
よ。次の社長がやっぱり優秀だったって
ことですよ。で、うちもそうなりますよ。
あと2年して次の台の社長に
アチューメント自体がいろんな意味でこっ
から飛躍してくと思いますよ。こんなもん
じゃないと思う。全然違うと思います。
やっぱりあの船内総権も船尾夫先生の台
から小山さんの台になって大きく伸びた
でしょ。創業者だから優秀っていうのは
それは0から10までは創業者かもしれ
ないけど10から100にするのは
やっぱりその文化で育って力のある責任感
のある人間で賢い人間がやっぱり次に
さらに大きくできるんですよ。でも目指し
てなければそうならないもんだ。持って
言ったら目指してない人間にその役職与え
ちゃだめだよ。そう思うよ。
だからその、ま、課長から部長に上がれない人間は器がちっちゃいんだよ、まだ。いや、本当求めるものはちっちゃいんだと思うよ。あの、キングダム見たら分かるよ。将軍になる人はどんな人かってのは、もうね、力がなくてね、戦っても弱いやつを将軍にしちゃだめ。本当に俺の大好きなわ辺奴隷の子上がってくじゃん。一生懸命練習して。もう俺だよ。
北海道から出てきてわべ死んだんだよ。
本当に僕はやっぱり天が味方する経営をし
たいと今を思ってるし本当に心から神様に
喜ばれる人生を全倒したいと思ってる。
ま、一言と言えばやっぱり相互的な能力な
んだけれどもだよ。やっぱりマインド
ノーハブスキルの器がちっちゃいなと思う
よ。うん。やっぱり体力がないんだろうな
。本当にね。自分のたったの人生をな何て
言ったらいいんだろう。命の花を咲かせ
るっていう
そういうね、やっぱり心しに生きて欲しい
ね。そういうものがないんだと思う。うん
。ちっちゃいんだと思う。だ、そこは
やっぱりでもそれはね、僕は長年ね、人の
成功と失敗と習慣について研究してきた
けど本当に人間ってね、考えた通りに生き
てるんですよ。すごいシビアだけど、自分
で自分の人生に限界を作らない方がいいと
思う。これだけは本当に1回だからお1人
様1回限りなんで本当に1回しか生きれ
ない人生だから是非頑張って欲しいと思い
ます。あの、是非ね、コメント欄に
コメントがあれば是非お願いします。
そして、え、是非ね、え、またチャンネル
登録、まだの方はチャンネル登録して
いただけると励めされます。また
次回おにりましょう。ありがとうございます。ま、今回僕嬉しいことがあってね、東京商候会議の第
号議員再戦果たしたんですよ。前回は表がね、それほど大きなをもらえなかった。でも今回は本当に嬉しかった。
3000秒超えたんですよ。そして76社
の第1号議員の中で28番目で当選したん
ですね。でもそれはなんでかって言ったら
俺一生懸命選挙活動したもんな。いや、
本当だから当初の議員になってく人でも
あまり選挙活動しない人もいると思うん
ですよ。俺したよ。なぜ?それ国に貢献し
たいからだよ。そういうことなんだと思う
んだよ。いやだ。これこな間だね、ある、
ま、経済団体でね、非営理組織はその経済
団体の場合は理事長っていう立場になる
じゃん。そ、理事長になりたくない人
ばかりで理事長になってくれないかって
頼んでるって聞いたのよ。俺もそれもダメ
だと。理事長になる人間っていうのは本人
がやっぱりその非営理組織の中でちゃんと
その地域社会に貢献する意識を持って私を
是非理事長にしてくださいとやっぱり
立候補するような意識俺の今当初の議員に
なったようにねそしたらどうすると思う?
年間のスケジュールで全部当初の
スケジュール確保すんだ俺たったってもし
頼まれてたとしたらあまり自分がそんな
やりたくなと思ったら当初のスケジュール
は出ててもそっち優先しないと思うよ。
そんな人間をね、また議員で選んでたら
当初だって衰退しちゃうじゃないですか。
だ、やっぱりそれなりにやっぱり頼む人
っていうか、そのね、当選してくる人間
ってやっぱり国を思い、ま、だからみんな
会長職とかある役割になってからそういう
公的なものに貢献してくんだけど、
やっぱり皆さん素晴らしい方多いよね。
Forユですよ。能力的にも高いし。だ
からまだまだやれるのにバトンタッチした
んだろうね。そうなんだと思う。まだまだ
やれる人ばっかりですよ。70代の人なん
だみんなバナバナやれる人ばっかりですよ
。でもあえてバトンタッチしながらさらに
次の役割を大きくしてってる。